everybody's favorite friendly
neighborhood spider-man is set to swing
back into theaters come july 2019 and
while audiences everywhere are all set
for another Spidey best marvel studios
sure is taking its time doling out the
details for now we'll have to settle for
these previously leaked tidbits and the
ever reliable rumor mill here's what we
know or think we know so far in January
2019 we learned that Nick Fury won't be
the only shield veteran returning to the
MCU and spider-man far from home so nice
to finally meet you spider-man
here in the cuny the first far from home
teaser trailer contained a brief shot
that showed a pair of characters who
seemed to be former SHIELD agent Maria
Hill and Nick Fury being attacked by an
elemental but fans were not entirely
sure until actress Cobie Smulders set
the record straight she posted a
screenshot of herself and samuel
l.jackson on instagram writing in the
photos caption it's me it's me I swear
the one on the left no not the monster
the one with the ponytail obviously
smolders was joking about anyone
confusing her with what appears to be a
massive sand creature though ironically
the last time we saw smolders as Maria
Hill was an Avengers infinity wars
post-credit scene when Hill and her old
boss fury were both dusted by Thanos his
decimation so maybe she wasn't joking
throughout 2017 spider-man homecoming
every attempt by Peter Parker to contact
Tony Stark or the Avengers was filtered
through starts pal happy Hogan portrayed
by MCU veteran Jon Favreau
we missed out on seeing happy in
Avengers infinity war so there was some
question as to whether or not the guy
whose favorite pastime was ignoring
Peter Parker would be around for far
from home we got our first inkling that
happy was returning in September 2018
when a reddit user posted a video that
appeared to show Favreau on the set of
far from home the return of happy was
finally confirmed in January 2019 with
the release of the first spider-man far
from home teaser trailer which featured
among other things happy getting flirty
with Aunt May nice thank you you too
thank you new dress yes it is I thought
you had all happened
what just happened it will be
interesting to see how if at all Happy's
new interest in Parker's ants will
affect the way he treats the young hero
who II doubt it September 2018 was a big
month for rumors and spoilers for
spider-man far from Hull but not all of
them were accurate along with the set
video that leaked jon favreau it was the
month super bro movies reported that
Gweneth Paltrow would appear and far
from home as Pepper Potts while Robert
Downey jr. and John Favreau had larger
roles in spider-man Home Coming Paltrow
appeared briefly in the film's final
moments for the spider-man press
conference that never happened did you
guys screw this huh he told the kid to
go wait in the car are you kidding me I
have a roomful of people in there
waiting for some big announcement what
am I gonna tell her we've since heard
that the rumor of peppers return in
July's far from home was a false one in
February 2000 nineteen Paltrow told
variety that April's Avengers endgame
will be her last film as part of the MCU
at least for the near future
Paltrow told variety I mean I'm a bit
old to be in a suit and all that at this
point but she didn't discount a brief
return in the future
Paltrow went on to say quote of course
if they say can you come back for a day
I will always be there if they need me
the tragic gwen stacy the girl Peter
Parker loved but couldn't save was
played by Bryce Dallas Howard in 2007
spider-man 3 next Emma Stone took the
role for the - Andrew Garfield Spidey
films with everything already going on
in spider-man far from home
it doesn't necessarily seem like the
ideal fit for her introduction but ideal
fit or not in December 2017
a number of supposed audition tapes
surfaced with different actresses
claiming to be vying for the parts of
Gwen Stacy in the next spider-man movie
iris Haller who's only credited work is
for a German soap opera is one of the
apparent hopefuls another auditioning
actress introduces herself only as Luna
and speaks with what appears to be a
thick French accent since the tapes were
leaked there's been no word on gwen
stacy appearing and far from home maybe
the recordings were intentional red
herrings
maybe they were fakes but time will tell
for sure early in November 2018 Marvel
launched a clock counting down the 240
days until the july 2019 release of
spider-man far from tall that specific
number had some fans claiming that Miles
Morales the version of spider-man
featured in 2018 spider-man into the
spider verse could be appearing and far
from halt come on Dean let's go
miles why is the number 240 significant
you asked it just so happens that
acclaimed writer and Miles Morales
creator Brian Michael Bendis ended his
tenure with Marvel's spider-man with
issue number 240 in May 2000 18 that's
all it took to get bands speculating
whether there is a connection between
the two numbers that's not much of a
confirmation that Morales will be and
far from home it could just be a
coincidence after all on the other hand
considering the undeniable success of
spider-man into the spider-verse
as well as the fact that a deleted
spider-man homecoming scene mentioned
two character miles by name yes I'm out
of them I'm not gonna make it
yeah I'm just ugh the notion of morales
appearing alongside Tom Hollands Peter
Parker maybe less a question of if than
a question of when in August 2000 18 The
Wrap reported that crazy rich Asians
actor Remy hai had been cast in
spider-man far from home as well someone
nobody seems to be entirely sure who yet
just about every noteworthy spider-man
bad guy has been rumored to be appearing
in spider-man far from home at one point
to another so with the exception of
vulture or Mysterio I could be
portraying just about any of them on the
other hand the Australian actors Chinese
ancestry the martial arts training he
received for his role in Netflix is
Marco Polo far from homes international
scope and reports of Marvel's developing
a film for shang-chi have all fed
speculation that spider-man far from
home could see Remy hai bringing that
character to the MCU on the other more
plausible hand shang-chi probably isn't
included in Sony's Marvel character deal
so Marvel Studios might not debut an
upcoming franchise character and a Sony
co-production but maybe hai could be
playing Martin Lee also known as the
popular spider-man villain mr-
while far from home already seems
stuffed with villains this film could be
setting up the Martin Lee character
who's a family friend to Peter and may
so he can go dark in a future movie
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stopper coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]